[Applause]
thank you so much Rebecca for the
introduction and also for some of the
other conveners and especially
authorship on how Mirage for inviting me
to moderate this panel I just have a
quick question is there some light up
here that we can use okay I got it it's
great okay so let me open this panel
with a few thoughts on the key theme of
our symposium being material and that
which is livable the theme of our panel
today as I think through these themes
also through my own work so what does it
mean to be material today at a time when
the limits of extracting the earth's
resources for profit are increasingly
becoming visible across the globe with
toxic leakages rising global
temperatures and the loss of hospitable
environments for both humans and
nonhumans many cultural critics
scientists and artists have recently
turned their attention towards
materiality and ecological processes the
hope of this turn toward the material
art argue is to reflect on their earthly
and often unintended consequences of
human structures of design as well as
the material conditions of social
inequality as they were produced in the
context of war resource resource
extraction and displacement to think
about scales in crucial here if we want
to account for the intertwined
relationships between the material and
the social the organic and artificial
we've talked about some of that
yesterday in some of the panels and
that's also to get a better sense of the
entanglement between bodies with a
microbes minerals plants or human bodies
on one hand and technologies on the
other hand so in my own work I've
approached being materials from a
particular place the city of Berlin
Berlin is a city that is so heavily
saturated with narratives about the West
and the violence that has
Cape 20th and 21st your century European
history of fascism displacement the Cold
War and the collapse of socialism all of
which can be traced in the cities
material fabric for this very reason the
city provides for me a productive site
from which to figure out how to create
alternative stories about material
things to illustrate that let me start
off with the curious story of a plant
that has occurred at a moment in which
the city's material fabric literally
burst apart and gave way to a sense of
the city as more than human habitat and
what I call ruderal City view of the
city in which nature is not there to be
managed controlled incorporated in
forensic organic urban landscapes we had
infrastructure and technology but an
integral and unwieldy part of the city
toward the end of World War two large
rubble fields started the heavily bombed
city of Berlin as the city grew
increasingly divided with the onset of
the Cold War many non-native plants
flourished in the city's rubble for the
first time one of these plants was Sikhi
goosefoot okay no podium buttress a
yellow-green flowering plant covered
with sticky hairs and a strong aromatic
scent sticky goosefoot was originally
imported from constantinople and
cultivated in gardens throughout europe
at the beginning of the sixteenth
century as a plant prospered for the
first time more widely beyond cultivated
gardens in Berlin's blasted landscapes
their widespread emergence triggered the
curiosity of West Berlin botanist
surrounded by the Berlin Wall and cut
off from their usual field sites in the
countryside to study the so-called
ruderal ecology of the city one of the
botanists who often now is referred to
as the father of urban ecology was
Harrison cook and here was an image of
him in the young verbena forest
so now the word ruderal comes from
Rudess which is the Latin word for
rubble it's a common term in urban
ecology that is used for plants such as
Keenan podium buttress they've produced
large numbers of seeds and are usually
the first to colonize disturbed
environments such as the sides of roads
and train tracks urban wastelands a
rubble field now Rudo plants have been
good for me to think to think west and
specifically approaching the question of
material materiality and life in my case
urban life on an increasingly damaged
planet rudos get us to think about three
aspects that I think will also hear more
about from our speakers today soil value
scale so in terms of soil rude rules
like C key goosefoot are able to grow an
environment in the city that are usually
considered hostile to life such as the
spaces alongside the city's
infrastructure or in rubble they depend
on an edge effect of contrasting
environments and they prefer dry
gravelly soils that are poor in
nutrients in fact they grow in soil that
is grow and thrive in soil that is often
at least partially covered with a
foreign substance such as cement or they
grow in their cracks as you can see in
this image value the first to inhabit
disturbed land disturbed lands rules are
not a nuisance in the sense of weeds
although they may be considered to be by
some they set the stage for other
flourishing ecosystems for example by
giving rise to spontaneous wetlands
attracting birds or providing shade and
organic matter important for other
species yet despite these ecological
benefits after world war two rules were
not simply a sign of regenerating nature
or a new life emerging out of the ruins
of the war as is depicted on the fifty
senac 50 pfennig coin that you see here
in the image camara commemorating not
only the rubble women but also women
reforesting the lock down forest and
thus rebuilding nature after the war
so rude rules instead where instead
where the outcome of a much more
ambivalent and in fact sticky and
radically changing urban ecology amid
the blasts blasted landscapes of war and
ecological disturbance by the mid 20th
century Berlin like other cities has
become hotter due to increasing traffic
densely built environments and
additional heat sources in the city and
on earth Saru Durrell's were that's not
only indicators with the city coming
back to life as was so key to the kind
of national narrative after the war but
they were also warning sign of global
environmental change and the destruction
that nationalism and racism have wrought
across the world after World War Two and
continues to do so today what is
interesting here is also that there is
an elemental to unexpected and
unrealized cosmopolitan potentials
hidden in the city the seeds of rural
plants have found their way into the
city via divers transport routes some of
them had crossed the city on the boots
of refugees or soldiers during the war
or ice via packaging material from
imported goods or via hay transported on
wagons by the Russian army other seeds
routes remained unknown now in my own is
no graphic work the story of ruderal
plants has led me to think across
different scales of analysis and engage
unlikely human and non-human neighbors
that shape urban life in Berlin so some
of these are the rubble of war but also
plants growing in its ruins rabbits
inhabiting the city's border
infrastructures as senior in an image in
the film rabbit alla Berlin to makeshift
urban gardens built by Turkish
immigrants in the great zones of the
nation staged here we see an image of a
Turkish garden that was built in the
shadow of the Berlin Wall and actually
built around a rule
three decree of him heaven - rusty
fences around refugee homes set up on
former military bases in the East German
forests where people who flee war and
conflict in this case Syria but also
Kenya and other places across Africa
once again inhabit Europe's ruins while
they try to get a new life on track now
as we'll think more through the
questions of the material in living and
dying in the following presentations
across different scale such as bacteria
oil money and other material matters we
don't only encounter life and livelihood
but also histories of violence
Deacon's decomposition and death now
feminists have had a lot to say about
how we relate to matter we are our tools
yet too often the history of technology
has been the history of man's
externalization in contrast animals
plants and matter but also women and
racialized others have been seen as
stuck in the in processes of
internalization simply adapting to
technology or controlled by it
this vitalism of technology depends on a
gendered and racialized binary between
technology as a form of externalization
and active and matter on the other hand
as passive or degenerate a feminist
science fiction writer whose alala grin
points out in her essay the carrier
bacteria fiction once you remove the
knife and spares from the human hero in
the history of tool-making and redefine
the emergence of culture not as one of
domination or exploitation but what but
as one of carrier back collection the
hero begins to look a bit more mundane
in fact without the Podesta of heroic
tool-making put in a pouch or basket he
looks more like a rabbit or a potato
perhaps in our analysis of the livable
end of being material we need a bit less
pipes networks and wires and instead
collect more stories about rabid
basket speeds and other illegal
hitchhikers and what about roadkill as
having said that and also getting ready
for the March for Sciences afternoon I'd
like to open our panel with the question
what might it mean to reclaim a
different sense of the material today
what might it mean to do work that both
focuses on damage but also on the desire
to make things livable and with that I
hand over the stage to Tom
[Applause]